the only thing that will really help you
is to develop the power to reshape the
relationship in a positive way
you can't do this as long as you're
caught up in your immediate reactions
active love gives you the power to
transcend them this is the real power of
a spiritual approach to psychology
it teaches you how to activate higher
forces which are stronger than your
emotions these forces won't replace your
emotions but they will transform them
as you stop wasting energy on
superficial annoyances the important
things in life will move you more deeply
the human ego doesn't like to experience
anything more powerful than itself the
more committed you are to this
vulnerable state
the more power you'll feel
this comes as a shock to most people
that's because they don't understand
what real power is
real power doesn't come from you as an
individual it comes from the fact that
you're channeling something greater than
you
when you have real power you have no
need to prove anything to anyone free of
your own ego you're functioning from the
highest Part of Yourself
in this state you can Inspire the higher
parts of those around you it's the only
way conflict is truly resolved
where is that from
um it is oh sorry
um it's called the tools by Phil Stetson
uh Barry Michaels Mitchells
um I just watched stats on Netflix which
is a really big mental health
documentary that was directed by Jonah
Hill
and it was kind of profound and I
started reading that book and I thought
that was really interesting
because coming here I was very nervous
and then I realized that
people's perceptions it's all just my
own construct that I've built in my own
head so I am where are you from Gracie I
am from two places
I am from Utica New York
which is a population of about 60 000
people and it's a refugee Haven so one
in every third person in my population
is a refugee
and then I am also from Ilion New York
which is a population of about five to
seven thousand people
and
um
I lived in Utica from the day I was born
until the age of five
and I always remembered love to be like
loving being a city kid my brother and I
would ride my bike down to the little
corner Bodega and uh
it was just really interesting but I
also grew up
in a very impoverished area of my city
on the east side
my dad was a hoarder so
when you walked into my house we had one
clear pathway everything was boxes up to
the walls
and cobwebs hanging down ripped
insulation ripped walls it was really
interesting
he had lived in that house since the day
he was born
both of his parents also died in there
has a lot of trauma
and my mom had kind of gotten very
depressed in the environment he sat in
his room all of the time
so when I was five she decided to leave
him
and
we moved on over to Ilion New York which
is quite a smaller suburb and much
different than I was used to
and
it was interesting I have a very deep
memory you know your memory starts
developing from the age of two to seven
I think I read so that's when you're
starting to get a sense of your
surroundings a sense of your nervous
system and observing everything around
you so it was quite a big shock to move
from everything
and
it made sense though my mom wanted to be
in the place where she didn't have to
have mouse traps all over and cobwebs
and
live like that
um
my father's always just been that way
and it's unfortunate
watching him
in that way but
when I was three I my therapist calls it
a form of molestation
I was uh
molested by my first cousin we had a
strong family Dynamic my entire family
was around my grandmother my grandfather
my brother my cousins everyone
and
I guess I had told my mom about it and I
don't remember much of the scenario
being three four years old
and
she decided that you know she took me to
the hospital and all that in the rape
kit they were like no there's no
penetration but he's still you know
would pleasure himself and then you know
finish on to me you know relieve himself
of whatever and
what sucked about that is I assumed it
was normal
because that's your family and you're
taught I think most people are taught
from a young age that your family are
people that you love and you trust and
they Unconditionally Love and trust you
and would never put you in Harm's Way
and always have your best interest at
heart
and um I assumed that because this
person was my family that and it wasn't
a wrong thing and I didn't see it
anything more than just like a weird
interaction and form of love whatever
that term is and
they were like you know they never let
us be in a loan in a room again and they
sent him to a thing I don't know if it
exists anymore but I kind of compare it
to like a Beyond Scared Straight program
but it's like shock Camp is where they
sent him and he was out of the picture
for a few years but then he came back
and we had all moved to Ilion so my mom
moved and then my grandparents followed
suit and then my aunt followed suit and
my first cousin and her two children
moved in with my grandparents and
everyone was just kind of conglomerated
in one little bubble there
and
I remember starting school
I was always the weird one
and I got bullied from a very young age
they used to tell me I had a big nose
they used to call me Matilda
I don't know why
um
so I just remember never really like
liking going to school because I just I
had a really hard time making friends it
was super hard for me
um and when I was about five or six
um my second cousin
was about the same age as me and they
had started getting curious and
you know we would often be naked around
each other in weird scenarios in my
grandparents house
um
in their room and I just assumed again
that this thing was normal and that's
just what families did and we were kids
and
I didn't think any different of it I
assumed that it was normal but I didn't
realize how much it would have a
profound impact on me and the way I
socialized
um and I remember telling my mom again
and she told my grandmother and
my grandmother was like you need to send
her to therapy I'm like six years old I
don't even know what's going on and I
remember seeing a therapist briefly with
my mom in the room and it was really
hard to communicate with her there
um but I kind of dissipated and never
really happened again after that and
from there I just you know I went to
school and
The Bullying was intense
um
as I got older I started reading and
that was great reading was a huge Escape
for me
I would read all the time every book I
could get my hands on
and that really helped me you know I
kind of didn't need friends my books
were my friends
and
it's yeah I just every moment I got the
chance to read I was reading and my
grandparents were very harsh so I often
tried to escape in that way sitting on
the couch sitting at the table being
outside reading my mom worked long hours
so they would often babysit me after
school
and my grandmother was very emotionally
abusive and very manipulative
so she would often find anything she
could pick on me for
um
just make me feel very unloved and it
kind of really set a weird precedent for
me because it's like this is family
someone I'm supposed to Unconditionally
Love but it doesn't seem like they're
reciprocating that back to me and I
never understood why but my mother had a
pretty traumatic childhood growing up so
it made sense
um
she has four other siblings and they
grew up in a very small town like
population 132 and
they moved around a lot as well and my
grandmother never worked until she got
married
for the fourth or fifth time
and
she just they were never attended to she
told my mom straight to her face one day
that she never wanted any of her
children she just wanted babies and once
they hit like two she didn't want them
anymore well you know once they could
become more self-sufficient she was like
you know you can walk do dishes do your
thing exist
um
and so it was really rough for my mom
you know she tells me some things and
she also was molested as a child so it
didn't make it any easier because
um the generational trauma just passed
right right down
um
So eventually
my mom kind of stepped them away because
I would just always complain that I
wasn't happy there with my grandparents
all the time
and you know she started trying to find
me babysitters and stuff but there was a
period where she had gotten a parasitic
infection so she was in the hospital for
like eight days and she couldn't
remember anything it was really really
terrible and I had had to stay with them
that entire time
and
I remember I was playing with my younger
cousin and
they said something and I can't remember
what the exact scenario was but I was
like well you're not that special
and he just started crying and he goes
and tells my grandmother
and she comes and just backhands me
across the face and she like drags me by
my hair into this chair
she makes me call my mother
who's in the hospital
with this insane infection and tell her
what had happened tell her that I told
my cousin exactly word for word that I
told him he wasn't special and
at that moment I kind of realized that I
had to silence myself I could never
stick up for myself
or say anything
because it had to be in that one way and
I think that ends up being true for a
lot of people in that kind of family
Dynamic especially more like
Suburban rural families that are used to
that same upbringing small town
so after that yes really when my mom was
like okay
and she had a couple of other
babysitters for me who were just as
intense
constantly bullying me progging me
um torturing me just making me feel like
it was a really terrible and ugly child
um
I never really understood it and I just
you know accustomed all of this to
normal this extremely normal thing like
this is you know it doesn't happen to
every kid but it must happen to most
kids and I kind of just
worked my way through it always kept to
myself I was always listening to music
music was my Escape
I'm very grateful there's this corny
quote used to be on a zoomy shirt says
when words fail music speaks but I
always remember that because it's very
true
um
so when I was about 10 my mom had gotten
a boyfriend
and he was a retired veteran he had
served about 10 years in Afghanistan
and he had a lot of PTSD
so we moved in with him
what was pretty briefly right after she
started the relationship and it was
about two months in and
always just had enough feeling but it
was my mom I didn't really want to say
anything
I couldn't really say anything because I
was a child what did I know
and
about three months into that
relationship and when we had moved into
him I had been dropped off by my dad
from school and he asked me to come
downstairs and
he said you're getting older and your
mom wants me to show you some things
and he taught me how to kiss how I'm
supposed to kiss a man
and mind you at the time he's like 35 37
years old and I'm about 10.
and
again he said that my mom was the one
who wanted me to do it so you know I
didn't want to question it as a child
you know you don't question your parents
or their decisions they always know best
and
so I just kind of
assumed it was this normal thing again
that was happening and it eventually
turned into a lot of extreme sexual
abuse afterwards
and so we had moved into his house which
was about 30 minutes away from where my
mom and I had lived and then we moved
back into our house
and it continued there and
he would often Force us to do things
like
[Music]
um
I don't know you're probably so long ago
feels like it's not that long ago but
like the Wii do you know what I'm
talking about like the Wii games so he
would make us all play that naked
together me him and my mom and my mom
was there and
I actually just talked to her about this
last week I'm like you know why did you
think that was normal for a 10 11 year
old girl to be naked around a
middle-aged man
and she said she
she didn't know and she should have you
know
um my mom's always been free-spirited in
the way where you know she could be
naked all the time she would you know
she could
find a way to function in society naked
I I think she would and that's beautiful
and I love that about her but um
I just always thought as a kid being
around men and being naked was extremely
uncomfortable
so and we would shower together to the
three of us and I just remember being
this extremely uncomfortable and
settling experience and I could never
vocalize it
and
finally I had just gotten so enraged I'd
gotten so depressed you know I couldn't
even read anymore listen to music I was
just
I couldn't function in school and nobody
at school was really picking up on the
signs either
um which was unfortunate because I feel
like if you know another adult could
have picked up on the signs
maybe something could have been done
about it sooner but everything happens
for a reason and I had
mostly great teachers so you know I am
I don't judge them for not reading the
signs it's hard to you know how do you
know especially when you're a kid and
you just accustomed accustomed to it is
normal or this thing and you don't
really talk about it
so we it continued for about two years
and he had gotten really bad he was an
alcoholic he was waking up and drinking
every day like
bottles of Jose Cuervo which is like the
worst tequila but I'm not going to not
going to judge someone's taste and
here
had just been gotten really bad and I
remember there was one night where I
just had gotten into a really bad
screaming rage and
you know and I called my mom my dad not
my mom she was there but I'd called my
dad and he was with my first cousin at
the time and I had called him to pick me
up it was like eight nine o'clock at
night and I was just screaming at him
and I was like you're a molester like
you're a child predator and
he was just laughing and he wasn't
saying anything
um you know and
my mom eventually my dad showed up and
they just like wait in the car I was
getting ready to go out my mom was like
nope you're staying here and she just
pulled me right back into it and I
remember going upstairs and
summing my door I was really angry you
know my dad who's supposed to be there
who's supposed to protect me who's
supposed to take me away from situations
like this um you know he still doesn't
even know to today what happened to me
as a child most of the time about 95 of
it he doesn't
even though
um
and I don't want him to know he had a
really terrible childhood
so it's just kind of easier in that way
um
and he has a couple of learning
disabilities so it's just
easier mentally because he just wouldn't
really understand
um
so I remember getting back upstairs
slamming my door and he gotten so angry
he drilled and took all the nails out of
my door and he took my door off
so now I'm this 11 year old growing girl
and I have no sense of privacy my
bedroom door has been taken off
um
which of course then makes it easier for
him to come into my bedroom at night
which he did
and
and my mom and I had a really deep
moving conversation last week and you
know and I told her I was like you know
why would you let someone do that you
know and
she goes you know I can name you 10
different parents that would have done
that if their child slammed the door
like that and I'm like and I can name
you 10 different parents as well that
wouldn't have done that
um
you know and
we just kind of let it go at that but
he eventually well my mom eventually
decided to leave it was really hard
leaving he threatened to burn our house
down and kill all of us in it which was
terrifying because I am this
preteen girl and I can't talk to anyone
at school about it and you know and
whenever I did threaten it you know he's
like who do you think they're going to
believe like I'm a decorated you know
veteran I am a you know I am a person
who has served and fought for this
country and you are a
small child and he would always use that
to his advantage and manipulation to
make sure that I always kept my mouth
shut
and she eventually left it was really
hard
um he threw a remote at her face one day
and I think that's really what kind of
drove her to leave and
we then moved in with my aunt who by the
way had also
slept with him so it was a really
uncomfortable situation because he
cheated on my mom with her sister and
now the three of us are in this house
together
um very small and you know he would
drive around the block he would
terrorize us for like the first three
months I remember him like popping my
mom's tires or just showing up uninvited
um
it really sucked it really sucked
um because I always just felt
uncomfortable around him I never wanted
my friends to come over because I wanted
to protect them from him
and there was a brief period where my
brother and my sister-in-law lived with
us too and I would always wait until she
went to bed or she was upstairs for me
to go to bed because I was just so
scared that he would do something to her
and
then we eventually moved out and it was
kind of a relief
um
it just felt like this extremely
traumatic period of life and felt like I
had lived 10 years in a matter of almost
two years
but it made me really strong which I'm
grateful for and it also taught me
the beauty of Silence because I think
had I had gone through and you know
really gone through the effort of
telling people which I think people
should
um I just felt like it would have done
more damage to me
so we moved in with my aunt and then we
moved in with my grandfather and
my grandfather had kind of known and I
don't know how he knew he just knew
and
we were in his car one day and he said
you know if something's going on you
need you need to tell me and he was like
so I can take care of it
and I was too scared because he's you
know he was in his 60s at the time and
he was this amazing man and I knew if he
really put his heart to it he probably
could have but I was just so scared he
was like the only man I could really
trust besides my dad and the only man
that I truly loved so I didn't want
anything bad to ever happen to him and
that's why I just kind of always kept
shut about it
and
during that time afterwards I became
extremely hypersexual I was the girl in
school everyone came to about sex
anything you wanted to know about sex I
am an open book I will tell you
everything you want to know I um
partial a lot of it is also because of
the internet I think a lot of you know
not even just my sexual abuse as a kid
but being exposed to porn at a very
early age created a lot of
misguidance for me because I was very
confused and I kind of all just looked
at it as the same
same thing
and
I also was
an Omegle kid I don't know if you've
ever heard of that website uh
pretty traumatic stuff happens on there
some pretty dirty stuff it was just like
this website where you could go on live
talk to strangers but you would see some
of the most disgusting terrible things
and my friends would just think it was
hilarious
um you know I mean we're all small town
kids and they're just you know seeing
things on the internet and thinking it's
not either real or it's just funny and
for me I just always remember being very
desensitized to a lot of
sex
thing sex culture
and
we eventually moved back to Utica and
that's just because the bullying at my
school had gotten really bad and I think
partial a lot of it was my
hypersexuality I um I got pregnant at 14
years old with the first person I had
conceptual sex with
and it was terrifying you know because
you're a girl you're having sex for the
first time it's supposed to be this
magical wonderful experience it was far
from that he was watching goosebumps in
the background
so it wasn't really that uh romantic
um and then you know your first time
having sex and then you know six seven
weeks later you're pregnant and I um I
didn't know what to do
and I'm very grateful for the couple of
girls that I went to school with because
one was able to get a test for me and
another girl's mom had like been like
hey like if you don't want to go through
with this
um you know they were willing to drive
me to Planned Parenthood so I'm really
grateful for that
small support system at the time and I
did but I told my mom so I ended up
getting an abortion at 14 years old
and it was a very traumatic experience
and I didn't really think about how much
it would impact my life
until the most recent years and I think
it's just because as a woman
you know we love to love and part of our
you know when we're connecting with our
womb and this sacredness you know giving
birth as a part of that having a child
as a part of that
and
it ended up creating a lot of pain for
me afterwards
because I just I didn't know how to be a
normal person I had to carry that on my
back for a long time you know and where
I was from abortions were controversial
there were girls that you know when I
was 12 years old that were pregnant and
there were girls at 14 years old that
were pregnant girls that were 16 on
their second kid and
um
I'm very grateful because I feel like I
wouldn't be where I am now if I had had
children I wouldn't be able to be
sitting here right now if I had had
children and be able to share my
experience or be as self-aware as I am
but there was a lot of trauma that came
after it so I ended up moving back to
Utica and we moved back in with my dad
um because at this time he
became a like disabled 100 so he has
sciatica
um all down his right side of his body
he has arthritis head to toe his heart
is functioning at 40 percent he has two
broken valves on top of a heart murmur
and he's 300 pounds
and he's a hoarder
so we moved back in with him my mom kind
of became his caretaker and
it was really stressful because you're
just watching this person who used to be
able to drive with and go to the movies
with and do things that can
no longer move
he can't lay down he can't
um you know he can't sometimes go to the
bathroom properly and he
for the longest time wanted shower and
he would just have this odor it was so
bad you'd walk into my house and
he just like I couldn't even hug my own
dad and then and that for me was like
the worst feeling in the world that I
couldn't hug my own dad because he just
he couldn't take care of himself
and
I pushed through it
and I graduated high school my last two
years I was homeschooled I had just had
gotten such bad anxiety it was so bad
that I couldn't even complete a full
school day but I really regret that
because my school had a program so a
tutor would just come to my house three
hours a day and I'm very lucky I was a
gifted kid and I was smart enough you
know in an honors classes that I could
you know just read three hours worth of
packets and retain all of my information
and go on with my day but I didn't
really get
that school experience my last two years
of high school and I also didn't I
missed out on a lot of socialization
that really set me far behind
socialization wise
so yeah my dad didn't even come to my
graduation that's uh and that was such a
huge milestone for me
um
you know my brother dropped out and it
was just really important to me that I
graduated high school and and all of our
business classes I had like the highest
GPA and I won this like 500 award I was
so proud of myself I was so excited
um
thank you
in high school yeah that was a really
interesting time my mom you know she
couldn't stand living with my dad so
we'd do anything to escape she put me in
All-Star Cheerleading
so I competed all over the U.S
nationally my last four years and
um I did some briefly I didn't compete
but the year after I graduated I just
like went to open gyms and stuff
um
and that kind of it was really fun and
the adrenaline rush sense I felt like it
kept me away from some hard drugs I feel
like I definitely could have gotten into
some really
hard drugs had I not had that sport as
an outlet I think certain Sports can be
really important but
what was unfortunate about that industry
is you always had to look a certain way
so you had to be a certain way to you
had to have your hair a certain way and
I just remember bleaching my hair every
three four weeks and I would just get so
tired of it in the spray tans I get so
tired of it I mean and that was just
grateful my mom could afford all of this
and we could do this and travel and and
have this fun but you know my my dad
could never come to any of it so it just
always felt like what was the point
um
so yeah we did that for a while and then
I eventually just got tired of feeling
like I needed to look a certain way I
couldn't be a Barbie doll I couldn't
lose enough weight I you know had
gymnast thighs you know I couldn't you
know be in the front for a lot of things
when I felt like I'd worked hard enough
so I
I left that
and it was kind of a sigh of relief
because I've felt like I was able to
start developing myself I didn't have to
have this personality of being a
cheerleader you know but I think it's a
great sport it's the most one of the
most dangerous sports in the world just
doing it I mean the tax it took on my
body afterwards um you know I have a lot
of issues that I have to deal with
because of it
and
I took a gap year after that everyone
should take a gap year after they get
out of high school I think that's really
important
there's one thing I can offer
take a gap year after high school I
was able to travel I went to Alaska and
that was so much fun I got to go on a
bunch of trains and it was just super
cool and then I ended up coming back and
I worked a couple of different jobs
which was great because it allowed me to
get so much experience I worked at a
Scenic Railroad I was a waitress I you
know I was working at an acai Bowl
restaurant and
was really awesome and then I decided to
go to college
my was the first time I was away from my
family I was about four hours away so I
was in Westchester New York which is a
beautiful place
and I was away from my family for the
first time and I was I was just so
grateful that I
went to college you know I only had one
other cousin that went to college and I
don't even know if she graduated or not
but nobody in my family had gone to
college really so it was just this huge
milestone for me because you know I'd
started drinking in high school
and it was really bad you know I was
drinking especially my senior year
because I was homeschooled I didn't have
anything to do I was drinking like one
or two bottles of wine a day and
it had gotten really bad and you know
even during all those jobs in my Gap
year before College you know I still
I still had a lot of falling out with my
mental health
um you know I started smoking weed and
weeds great
um
I weed allowed me to really dig deep
within myself and creatively explore
myself as an individual and and it
reduced a lot of anxiety that I had and
I think in a medicinal sense cannabis is
great but um
cannabis induced psychosis is also real
and that's something that scares me as
more places continue to legalize it
um
because that can really set you back as
well
um
so I went to college I was drinking a
lot smoking weed a lot but I was doing
really well I was making friends I was
doing classes and that was great
I love to learn I'm a lifetime learner
if I could do any if I could be paid to
go to college for the rest of my life
and learn everything about everything I
would because I love to learn I think
life is all about learning and you know
I just I just loved learning so much and
it took a lot because you know I I was
extremely traumatized I was extremely
hypersexual and at College I was hoping
to get away from all of that I didn't
want to date I didn't want to have sex
and
I think I was maybe like a month into
this semester when I had
been on a dating app but I was mostly
looking for friends and which is a joke
because dating apps are just meant for
insecure people trying to fill a void
and
um so I would match with a lot of people
and then I would meet and then they're
like oh I want to have sex with you not
hang out with you and I'm like okay
um because I was wearing vulnerable and
insecure at the time and I was like well
at least I'm getting paid attention too
and you know making friends and if this
is the way I make friends this is the
way I make friends
um
and there was a night where I had made
friends with a student and he was like
I'm really drunk I can't go back to my
dorm can I stay in your dorm and
I was like sure
um and I had told him I was like you're
drunk I don't want to have sex with you
like please don't have sex with me
um and he forced me to have sex with him
anyways
um
and then I just had to go back to normal
after that I went to a super small
college so we saw each other all of the
time you know and I already
know how bad it is when it comes to
college students and sexual assaults you
know I mean it's just
it happens all of the time and
universities don't really do anything
about it or advocate for the people that
go through it so I just you know I don't
really want to go through a whole
process they were you know pretty high
up at the college and I just didn't I
didn't want to waste my time and my my
mental energy to have to go through that
but I pitied myself a lot because I was
like again like come on like you know
like you've been through this so much
from a child now you're an adult you're
a grown woman and you're just still
letting people take advantage of you and
manipulate you and you're not saying no
and you're not learning your boundaries
and and why are you not doing that
um
and then I got my first college
boyfriend
and he had a
disassociative Identity Disorder so that
was really intense because I'm a person
with extreme childhood trauma anxiety
um
I had a bit of a substance abuse issue
and they had this severe mental illness
working through that
relationship was really interesting
because there were moments where it was
really beautiful and Love's great you
know it doesn't matter I mean even if a
person has you know a mental illness you
know you can still find to love deeply
and have a wonderful relationship and we
did
but um it just gotten so bad for both of
us we've just been trauma bonding so
deeply at that point that I just had
gotten
too much
so we called things off which was great
because a worldwide pandemic decided to
happen my second semester of college
um
so it was like a week
we went back to school after break and
then it all started happening
and they weren't sure whether or not
they were going to send us home and
then there was a day where they like you
have 72 hours you have to get all your
stuff out you have to go
so
I went back home
and that was really rough because it was
finally I'd Escape my family I'd Escape
my life I was starting a new life for
myself I was figuring myself out and and
not not many people get the opportunity
to do that and I was so grateful and
humbled for that experience
and then just to have it all ripped away
taken away and I can't blame a pandemic
but it just it sucked it was like it was
like my entire heart and soul had been
like chewed through and I just had to
you know I had to start all over again
and
my first cousin who had
molested me when I was three years old
had now moved in with my parents because
he had been kicked out of his house
so when I was coming back home he had
been sleeping in my bedroom for like
three months and my mom didn't know how
to tell me she avoided telling me for
the longest time because it's like how
do you tell this person that's hurt your
child that they're now sleeping in your
bed
and during that time
I had a lot of time to reflect and and
take time to myself and ask my mom
questions about his childhood and
you know he had it pretty [__] up as
well
um
according to my mom you know like his
parents would like have sex in front of
their kids like it didn't matter if it
was one o'clock and like his dad wanted
to have sex and like his mom was out in
the kitchen they were doing it on the
kitchen table
and he was exposed to sex at a very
early age and
my brother says he got suspended at nine
years old for having sex on the school
bus so I I'd kind of Taken time to
reflect on a lot of that
and
I forgave him
[Music]
because he he didn't know any better he
only knew what he was brought up with he
only knew that that form of sex and that
form of of love and that's really hard
to sit and forgive someone and then
continue to let them live in your home
and sleep in your room and and coexist
it took a lot out of me
but it's much easier than living life
and anger and In Spite and in sadness
and feeling like the victim
because I am a survivor I'm not a victim
and then also you know we we're just
products of our environment and that was
our environment
and I could hate him for the rest of my
life or I could move on from the
situation because he never did it again
and it was the same way with
the boyfriend that my mom had had you
know I mean what was his childhood like
you know I don't know and I remember the
day I forgave him too I had
gone to church I briefly play around
with religion and I had gone to church
one day I was about 15.
and I can't really remember what was
said but I remember it being so moving
and after that I decided to forgive him
too because I didn't know his upbringing
I didn't know his background I don't
know what he went through as a child
and then on top of that to fight in a
nasty war and to be you know a part of
that fighting for your country that's
extremely traumatic as well and to have
you know complex post-traumatic stress
disorder on top of that
um I could spend the rest of my life in
anger or I could forgive them because
you know
um
and Buddhism when you have you know even
just the slightest instant of anger
um you know it destroys Eon so if you're
good karma that you've made for yourself
so I was like if I'm angry at them and
it's never going to do anything for me
I'm going to continue escaping I'm going
to continue drinking I'm going to
continue smoking I'm going to continue
trying different things and
I just didn't want that I didn't want
that for myself and it's hard because
not a lot of people can reach that level
of self-awareness where they can fully
forgive someone for doing something so
terrible to them and then on top of that
let one of them live in your home or
sleep in your bed after that
but I'm very grateful that I did and
it's done some very controversial it's
very controversial for me to say that
because there are so many people that
have been abused and they have the right
to be angry and they have the right to
be upset and they have the right to not
forgive
but the problem is is that
when you're not forgiving them you're
also not forgiving yourself for knowing
that you didn't know what was going on
at the time you know when you were a
child
and I needed to forgive myself and by
forgiving myself I was able to forgive
them too
I kept doing classes online I took a
semester off like the second semester of
covid
and then I
um went back for another semester at the
same college and I had met my second
partner at that time ex-partner
and they had a really heavy addiction
so it was they were smoking a lot
drinking a lot they had been
experimenting with other things and
I had kind of delve into that and
they came from a very privileged
background so they could kind of get out
of anything their parents would take
care of it and
it was a beautiful relationship they
were probably the person that really
taught me like what love is what to be
loved by another person is and to be
taken care of
um
But ultimately
they kind of chose that lifestyle over
me and that was something I didn't want
anymore I wanted to wake up every day
feel grateful for life
I hated waking up and just like smoking
weed all day you know it's fun at first
when you're waking and baking but after
that you kind of just want to
live life and see something else
so I moved to Colorado
and I started school at a Buddhist
University because I had done a lot of
yoga and meditation over the pandemic
and that truly changed my life I
wouldn't be able to deal with my trauma
or sit here and be here talking to you
if I had not learned yoga and meditation
I wouldn't be able to
stop myself from doing other substances
you know when I tried Xanax I was just
you know on it I was trying it I was
doing it a lot every day and
over the pandemic it's hard you know
you're isolated what else is there to do
especially if you're in a smaller place
so I went to college I went to Colorado
um
didn't know anything about it before I
moved there I just moved there never
thought I'd end up there and
it had gotten very hard to live there
it's very expensive and when you don't
come from a wealthy family it's even
harder to afford it there so I
got into sugaring on a website called
seeking Arrangements
which is where you sleep with older men
for money
and I started doing that because I had
wanted to continue living in Colorado
where I was living
and I just loved it there and I was so
far away from everybody I didn't have to
worry about anything you know I still
had to worry about my dad he was
hospitalized like three times during the
time that I was there
and
it was an easy business because I'm very
business oriented in this sense that I
knew how it worked you know I read a
bunch of Reddit threads I watched a
bunch of videos and I was like okay if I
take it from like a dominatrix
standpoint and I do this in a way where
it's like okay
there's you look at the demographic of
the people on the website there's men
that are lonely there's men that are
very discreet you know married have
children or in their business doing
their thing but obviously aren't happy
in their lifestyle or their marriage so
I come along and it was very easy to
start pickpointing and because I'd been
exposed to the internet at a very early
age I was able to kind of fish out
scammers like I was like okay this
person's not real this person is and it
was a very easy way to get quick cash
and allow me to continue living in
Colorado
and
I was pretty I was pretty good at it was
pretty easy because a lot of the times
you know I was really good at like
picking out the men and a lot of them
like half the time I wouldn't even have
sex with them I'd just be like their
personal therapist for an hour or two
um or they couldn't get hard so like
they would just pay me to lay down with
them and that was super easy I was like
oh great this is a great business I
should have been you know I should have
started this earlier and
eventually that got tiring too because
you're doing it all the time and it
becomes like a full-time job and for me
it was more so like not really a hobby
but an extracurricular activity that I
had taken up and was enjoying
so I kind of you know I kept doing it
and
I had to move out of Colorado because I
was in a really shitty roommate
situation
um and they had been using a lot of
drugs and getting in a lot of like been
doing a lot with it and I just didn't
want to be a part of that I was trying
to get sober I when you're in Colorado
all you do is drink and smoke and I was
doing a ton of mushrooms too which you
know I love mushrooms psychedelic
medicine changed my life
but it just wasn't feasible for me to
live there anymore because I knew it
wasn't the best for my mental health so
I
had gotten out of there and I'm grateful
because you know a lot of people that
I'd end up meeting on seeking
Arrangements the one thing I hated about
it is they would just like all fall in
love with me because I'm a very
vulnerable and emotionally intelligent
self-aware person and a lot of these men
especially if they were married for 20
30 years and like had no idea how to
live life after getting divorced so they
were just like you know I brought a very
youthful energy to them and they really
enjoyed that about me because I could
make them feel comforted safe and
nurtured and I brought that
um
and it was great because you know I met
a lot of great people that helped me and
supported me in doing the things that I
wanted and you know and occasionally
still do if I need it
um but it was a tiring lifestyle because
it's like a lot of them are drinking a
lot of them are sometimes using drugs
too and even though it's a lot different
from you know prostituting per se
um you know it was just like a tiring
lifestyle where it's like you know
especially if I'm spending the night
it's like oh I just have sex with you
like five times a day you know and like
this is the only way I'm gonna get paid
like you know we can't just sit here and
have a heart-to-heart conversation and
be too humans functioning in a in the
same space like I just have to
be this you know Illuminating Sexual
Energy person and give you that so I can
get money so I can just afford to live
all of it was out of survival it was
more so I want to escape my family I
want to provide myself a good life I
want to learn how to do things you know
I never learned how to be financially
free or successful and
doing that allowed me to learn how to do
those things because a lot of them were
very open
um you know Colorado I think is one of
the best places to get in the sugaring
because a lot of them are extremely safe
A lot of them are very easy to get along
with and find
and not worrying about scammers and just
being treated really well so I'm very
grateful because it wasn't an entirely
terrible experience for me I don't
regret it
um
but it was just it got really exhausting
it was so emotionally exhausting and I
just gotten really depressed
so do you feel like the
sexual
things that happened to you as a young
girl
played in it oh absolutely open the door
for that oh yeah to happen 100 I would
not I would you know
I when I was at my first college in New
York you know I thought about doing it
but in New York City it's extremely
dangerous it's so much more bigger and
you know dudes would be like let's meet
at Grand Central I'm like I'm not
meeting you at Grand Central Station
absolutely not so I didn't do it
and you know and it was a very emotional
at that time and then when I was in
Colorado I finally someone I knew had
been doing it so that's why I was like
okay well this person's doing it and
they're alive and they're safe so you
know green light I'll go and do it
um
but yeah I feel like if I'd never been
sexually abused as a child or been
exposed to porn at a very early age I
probably never would have done it
um but you know I started looking at it
more from a business aspect and you know
and a lot of the times I wasn't even
having sex with them
so it ended up working out just as well
because it was like half the time I was
just paid to be like a companion and I'm
pretty good at that
so I was doing that and then I moved
back in with my mom and I was doing it
for a little bit there with her not with
her but like in the house like living
co-living with her and
I was just so depressed I stopped
and it's so easy I mean for some people
it's not that easy because unfortunately
for some people it's all they know and
I'm very grateful that I have I got the
opportunity to stop and I have a job now
and I can do things for myself and you
know I'm still living paycheck to
paycheck and that's okay
um how old do you know 22 22. and I feel
like I've gone through a million
lifetimes I'm very grateful for it all I
mean some of it's really awful and you
don't think about it you know but it's
like I just sit back with complete
gratitude because
all of it has shown me how to be a true
human what that means
um
and it's shown me a lot of light
and that's really hard for a lot of
people to say because you know once
you're caught in Lifestyles like that
it's very hard to get out of it
um I've been sober from weed for like 60
days now
which is really good because I hadn't
taken a break from it in like three
years
um and I've been sober from alcohol for
like almost 30. no it's been past 30
days now
and I haven't been doing ketamine in a
while either which is great
um
and
really just you know I mean it was all
an experience and I'm grateful for the
experience but a lot of it was really
related to my trauma and what it did and
it showed me you know and this is what
it's like and
you know the reason I am here is because
we have the collaborative vision of
making sure that this doesn't continue
in future Generations you know and I see
my family my nieces you know going
through a lot of you know not the sexual
trauma but emotional trauma and I see
kids around them going into all that
trauma you know especially when you're
stuck in areas like that that are more
impoverished and you don't really have
you're not exposed to anything else
because you become accustomed to it as
normal and it's not normal it's not
normal and there's so much more to life
than your insecurities and your family
and
you know my dad's in the hospital right
now and and I I made the effort to come
here and do this because for me
sharing this and letting people know
that
there is hope and you can get out of it
is so much more important to me you know
um
I've been studying Tibetan Buddhism for
two years and you know there's this
concept of a bodhisattva and it's where
you risk obtaining Enlightenment for
yourself for the sake of all others and
I feel like for me you know this is a
vow in doing that because it's been so
hard to wake up every day to go to work
you know with everything that I've gone
through it gets so exhausting you know
there are days where I don't want to
wake up there are days where you know I
wish I didn't wake up and I do and I
make the effort and it's so difficult
and it's difficult now to not you know
download seeking go on seeking and and
gain more money than what I'm making now
but it's just at the risk of what it was
doing to me at the risk of me finding
Simplicity and happiness it wasn't worth
it anymore
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in all of this
um
you seem like a pretty wise 22 year old
yeah
patience
I have a tattooed
patients it taught me a lot of patience
you know because throughout all of the
bad there's good you know I'm here right
now
how amazing you know when I was I
remember being 12 years old I used to
lay down by my bed and pray God please
don't let me live past 17 years old I
don't want to be alive I didn't want to
I didn't my cousin killed himself when
he was 24 years old and
I didn't want to be alive I I just I
didn't want to live
and to be here to be sitting here I mean
just to be living I never thought I'd
even see Los Angeles in my lifetime and
here I am and
all of this has just taught me to have
patience with myself with others
very grateful for it all right so Gracie
thank you so much for sharing sorry it
took so long